[Music]
Hello, I'm Michiel from Belgium and I
work for the European
Commission. My name is Michiel. I'm
37 years old and um, I'm Belgian. 10 years
ago I started working for
the European Commission in Brussels as an
economist. I currently work  for the uh
department for competition policy of which
I am part for the team uh that
enforces state aid rules for banks
and in this way uh I try to
contribute to ensuring that government support for banks does
not distort too much fair competition on the European market This is not
my  first job at the commission uh
during my first VI years at the
commission I worked on the
economic and budgetary supervision of
Italy one of the largest eurozone
countries in my daily work I
regularly have to deal with uh sensitive
files uh that are interesting and
intellectual  raise challenging questions,
for example on an economic or
legal level and, uh, I think it
gives a lot of satisfaction to solve those questions
together with, uh, my team members,
uh, and also the
policy agreements with other
interested parties such as other
departments within the committee or
national governments  from Member States or
other EU institutions such as the European
Central Bank and sometimes I even have to travel for that,
which is also nice of course, for
example three months ago,
I was able to attend a hearing at
the Court of Justice of the EU in
Luxembourg for one of my files and
that was a very interesting experience
and finally what I also really like
about my work is that there are a lot of
opportunities to take training courses
both internally and externally, for example in
my first job at the committee I was
able to take an Italian language course
and I also had the opportunity
to attend a three-week summer school
in London on banking
and
finance.
One of the things we
like most about working for the European
Commission is the internal job mobility.
In fact, you can have a whole career.  fill
with different jobs at the committee
the committee makes policy in uh
many different domains So there are
countless interesting roles that you
can switch to during your career and
in my case for example uh 5 years
ago I changed jobs within
the committee and that was  a very good
decision for my own personal
development but also to get to
know other policy areas and
of course to meet new colleagues
another thing that really
appeals to me about working for the
committee is the fact that it is a very
international work experience with
colleagues  who come from all corners of
Europe, for example, in my own
team where we have about 30 people, there
are no fewer than 12
different nationalities and that is
a true reflection of the
diversity in Europe and finally
I think that eh the European Commission is
really a  unique organization is a
unique governmental and political
institution uh that is central to the
European integration project uh a
project that uh is in the general interest
of our continent and its citizens and a
project that I personally believe very strongly
in and that uh motivates me every day
day in and day out in my
[Music]
work